shiny
a few weeks ago I posted the top 10 new
anime fights from 2020 to 2022 and guess
what it was a hit it's not a lot of
surprise there because it's pretty much
established that you love to watch
action sequences and the most
breathtaking battles that anime has to
offer so I figured why wait much longer
for that Volume 2 I suggested so that
Volume 2 is happening right now to add
to that I'll also be mostly talking
about long Runners and sequels because
now that we've got the new blood out of
the way on the previous list let's focus
on some of the old guns and let them
join in on the fun and that's why we're
starting off with Dorma and gunha versus
misaka
[Music]
the glory
the railgun and index series have been a
Hallmark franchise of the mid-2000s and
why its Glory days are long gone railgun
T released just two years ago provided
some of the best we've seen out of the
franchise in the way of anime it's
pretty much unanimous that railgun T is
the best railgun has ever been the one I
won't pin all that on the fight scenes
the climactic battle in The Season's
first Arc is certainly a sight to see on
one corner we have misaka in her most
brutal we've ever seen her so far and
then on the other side we have Thoma and
his ever trusty imagine breaker but in
this case he's not alone as he has help
in the form of gunha one of the renowned
top 10 strongest espers in Academy City
it's a fight that goes beyond what you
would typically expect out of the genre
with a lot of awesome special effects
and a substantial amount of strategy
involved Thoma and gunhar showed some
chemistry here and it's pleasing to see
the callbacks and payoffs to Dorma and
misaka's relationship put on display in
this fight railgun T is probably the
last we'll see of the a certain
franchise in anime form in the
foreseeable future but at least they
ended it on a bang
[Applause]
[Music]
Ki light novels how about seo's birkoli
versus Vector
sao's world of Underworld Arc lives up
to its billing they promised a war and
we've got a war full of awesome fights
it's Sao fighting in a scale we haven't
seen before there are lots of good
fights featuring the side characters who
rightfully got their shine thanks to
Kirito being out for most of the arc but
the one that everyone remembers is bur
Coley versus Vector this is a fight that
left quite an impression we all know A1
always adapts Sao with care if we're
talking about the production side of
things but this fight went Far and
Beyond what we know of how about some
special effects Insanity that would
typically only expect out of the biggest
Shonen titles in recent years how about
giving bacoli a glorious exit that a lot
of Side characters can only dream of
defeating the supposed last boss of the
whole Arc in doing so too gray fights
with lots of stakes and drama people who
love SEO for the eye candy will find the
expectations blown away by this I would
have said that like the a certain
franchise SEO is on its way out having
adapted all the web novel content and
waiting for the final light novel Arc to
be wrapped up but in the meantime we
have the progressive movies to keep us
company how about taking the Trek back
to iron credit and re-experiencing the
magic of 2012 only in a much better
paced form this time
[Music]
we proceed with Trevor vs death from
Castlevania
I say that part of enjoying an anime
battle is the immersion aspect of it for
gamers who tuned into the Netflix
Castlevania this fight featuring Trevor
taking on death has that in Spades the
whole fight wouldn't look out of place
in an actual video game with its strong
dialogue meticulous movements and a boss
monster that Towers over the hero even
the way death attacks and Trevor
responds really makes it look like
you're watching a playthrough of a video
game it even has that residual damage
thing going on if you pay some extra
attention if you're looking for the most
genuine Castlevania experience without
actually wanting to pick up a controller
this anime is probably the best you'll
ever get for it and that for me makes
this fight such a huge win
next up is a staple favorite from my
hero Academia Endeavor versus high-end
no move
now when we think of my hero Academia we
often think of awesome moments featuring
the main Heroes you know the students or
all might but somewhere in the mix of
main characters or even main villain
fights we have this you know what it is
the fight where we first got a chance to
see Endeavor at Peak Performance
Endeavor versus nomu is one of those
fights that didn't have as much history
or background revolving around the two
combatants to build hype but when you
see the actual fight you realize it
doesn't need to we have some dramatic
Stakes however as Endeavor will be
facing a tremendous test as the new
number one hero mostly though it's the
actual fighting that does all the
talking with Hawks in tow it's a clash
that lets the heroes dig deep into their
arsenal of tricks and show off their
destructive capabilities there's also no
shortage of drama as the battle was
quite Touch and Go featuring some close
calls for Our Heroes overall a great
fight the mha fans rightfully remember
it's one of the best the show has given
us in the past few years
Naruto makes a triumphant return into
action in this ishiki fight
when boruto got announced we all knew it
would be a matter of time before Naruto
finds his way back into action and it
didn't take too long at all after all
Naruto has had a couple of notable
fights in the sequel series already but
did anyone anticipate him getting a new
form and engaging in such a hype fight
like the one he had with ishiki I mean I
didn't there's not much build needed for
this moment after all ishiki had already
shown his capabilities by defeating
Naruto once this is a old protagonist
attempt at Redemption and in doing so he
unlocks baryon mode before giving us one
of the most insane fights boruto has to
offer it feels like we're back in the
old days with this one doesn't it see
Naruto throw hands of fire off wrestling
guns with this much impact the attacks
came in Fast and Furious and it really
reminds me of how much I loved it when
Naruto fights combined with magical
powers with hand-to-hand fighting the
movements were all sharp precise and
deliberate most importantly however is
the aftermath with such a Monumental
battle a new form as this we needed
nothing short of drama at the end of it
all and the con consequences of
unleashing this new form hits hard
you know what else it's hard seeing the
engagement numbers go up so here's
another segue for me to tell you to hit
the like button if you're liking the
video so far
terms of sheer grit and emotion not a
lot can top this is something Gintama
has always excited showing the heavy
emotions in its top fight it's a
no-brainer that this finale has that
aspect in Spades Gintama isn't the
traditional Shonen where it's all about
the reality warping powers or the fire
breathing but it's mostly about the
emotional Stakes the drama the sheer
Outburst of feelings that get put in
each strike in its fight the battles are
short and drama heavy and that's what
makes this finale so cool the funny
thing about this fight is that we've
already been teased about it way before
back when everyone thought dakasugi is
going to be the end game Boss like it's
a spoiler that only served to up the
anticipation and when we finally get to
this moment it's a classic bait and
switch to give us this classic not only
is it filled with emotional Stakes it
also has a lot of callbacks to the past
and I think those only strengthen the
fight in how it showed character
development the whole thing didn't end
in a bang or an over-the-top attack they
didn't need to the dead silence and the
short but decisive shots they did the
trick in the end it takes his time to
let the whole sequence sink in for us
and I love it for that very reason
land and go to the nice territory with
Oya versus Mast outcasts
[Music]
[Music]
here's something that you may not have
seen well probably it's because it's in
the third season of hitori noshita a
series that I feel no one else watched
it's not something with a lot of hype
behind it so it didn't seem to be
something to get excited about that is
until you see the action this by far is
the best animated fight sequence we have
to offer on this list it's just insane
how Sleek everything looks it doesn't
sacrifice impact for all the smooth flow
and emotions it really is power behind
those blows as the characters engage in
hand-to-hand combat this is truly an
example of the anime team working
overtime and showing their prowess in
the field of animation and I think it's
something that you should definitely
check out
we move on with everyone versus kaido
capping off a long-standing conflict
that's defined a big part of One Piece
this has been a long time coming within
the gallery of One Piece villains I
don't think anyone comes to the level of
hype that kaido has none of them had
this whole super overpowered wrecker of
Worlds appeal before at least not to the
level that kaido does even though they
all have their share of Feats and have
him team with big mom too it's the
Unholy Alliance that would take the
might of not just the straw hats to
overcome and long before the Day of
Reckoning had come The Clash against
kaido and the Beast Pirates gave me
nothing but pure anticipation the fight
took a long while and there are so many
moments that you just gotta see to
believe however it never felt dragging
in any way even if we got thrown
multiple phases of the fight in the end
it did come down to Luffy versus kaido I
love how this fight is long yet it never
got boring because it shifted actors in
and out all the while giving the fight
new twists and turns
[Music]
[Applause]
oh going on
demon Slayers here as expected and we're
looking at the hero group versus [ __ ]
and guitaro
and while it didn't have the year-long
height that the final kaido
confrontation had this Demon Slayer
fight employed the same techniques that
the former one did it's long pretty much
taking up around half of the season but
it never felt boring because like the
whole kaido fight we get to see the
characters mix it up and fight the
battle in multiple phases in a way it's
like the characters tagged each other in
and out with how the characters Central
to this conflict changes and everyone
gets to show off in various moments what
makes this fight even better is the
signature artistic Flair of Demon Slayer
it's been there ever since but it goes
especially well here now that they're
fighting in an Entertainment District
whole classic there to feel is just so
fitting here as always there's a lot of
notable moments that take place here and
having them paced well really helped
extend interest in this battle while
keeping it fresh with every episode
there's no best moment I can pinpoint to
be honest but I consider this as a
combination of a lot of events to
remember from nezuko first getting to
fight seeing the main group sheer
determination and wits to Simply ten gen
being awesome kudos to the villains for
coming up with some great strategy too
foreign
[Music]
cinematic anime at its best this my
friends is what top tier animation looks
like and with the free range ufoot table
got for a theatrical production the team
went all in on a fight that will very
well give the Demon Slayer fighter run
for their money compared to something
like unlimited blade works heavensfield
is a tad for you in the number of big
fights however they do make up for it
with quality we've got to see some
amazing ones every movie but this one
serves as the perfect climax to it all
it's truly a joy to be able to watch
this in cinemas the scene just isn't
complete without the sound quality a
theater provides the compliment the
already eye-popping special effects and
animation being thrown at you from the
big screen watching it on Netflix well
it just doesn't compare from a storyline
perspective I also like this because for
one we're giving some Rider love Ryder
always loses early on in other routes
but this is the first time we see her
unleash her full power and it's nothing
short of Glorious if you're someone who
looks at fights in terms of production
special effects and sound that pushes
the whole encounter Beyond its limits
and this is the fight for you
how's that for your 10 fights featuring
sequels this time around don't forget to
like And subscribe if you enjoyed the
video and if you're up for more why
don't you check out the channel also
come follow Vinnie tube on social media
through the links in the description box
once again thank you for watching I hope
that I can see you next time stay cool
stay awesome and I'll see you again